j.c and the generous poor you want him
as a bartender at your party
a treat for bridgeton fans that a new
movie explores deep friendship during
troubling times dania bacchus has your
ion entertainment report
three friends come together after a
devastating diagnosis in the upcoming
movie
our friend how you feeling tired thanks
for being here
i won't miss it the film based on a true
story follows journalist matt teague
whose best friend moves in after
teague's wife is diagnosed with cancer
our friends starring casey affleck
dakota johnson and jason siegel is
playing in select theaters
and on demand today filming for the
marvelous mrs maisel season four is
underway in new york
rachel brosnahan who plays comedian
midge maisel posted a picture of herself
inside a bubble on her instagram page
saying that production looks a little
different this year no word on when the
new season will be ready for streaming
all is fair in love and war
and netflix runaway hit bridgerton has
been renewed for a second season
the shonda rhimes produced regency era
drama follows the eight siblings of
london's well-to-do bridgeton family
as they pursue love and avoid scandal
season two will feature eldest brother
anthony's quest for a suitable wife
filming begins in the spring that's your
ion entertainment
donya back is cbs news los angeles
so much to watch right well if you're
having a hard time right now picking a
new show or movie
netflix hopes to help you out launching
a new shuffle option this year
it'll find your random show or movie
based on things you've already watched
they hope it'll make all the options a
little less overwhelming
no date yet for when it'll launch but i
like that idea christian
well bad news for james bond fans the
release of the latest film
no time to die has been postponed for a
third time
due to the pandemic's effect on the film
industry the new
official release date will be october
8th 2021
directed by kerry fukunaga it stars
daniel craig as double07
rami malik and anna de armas
now no time to die is the latest film to
get pushed back yet again let's take a
look at
some other highlighting anticipating
films where they stand as of now
the next installment to the marvel
cinematic universe black widow starting
scarlett johansson is sticking to its
may 7th release date for now
it's been delayed twice since it's may
20 uh 20
2020 release date i should say tom
cruise's top gun maverick
is slated for this july and who you're
going to call ghostbusters afterlife
will arrive in theaters in november